à notre invitation pour cette audition
donc nous achevons pratiquement
aujourd'hui en tout cas la semaine
prochaine nos travaux sur la commission
d'enquête sur l'efficacité des
politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique que nous avons
débuté à la fin du mois de janvier nous
les avions débutés volontairement avec
l'audition de l'ensemble des ministres
qui depuis 2012 ont eu en charge les
portefeuilles de la transition
écologique de transition énergétique et
ou du logement et nous achevons nos
auditions avec les trois ministres qui
aujourd'hui sont en charge de ces
responsabilités donc votre collègue
Madame Agnès panier renacher que nous
venons de nousditionner vous-même et la
semaine prochaine le ministre du
Logement Olivier Klein donc vous occupez
cette fonction depuis juillet 2022
auparavant auparavant vous avez été de
nombreux mandats électifs et plus
particulièrement ceux de mer d'Angers de
2014 à 2022 de sénateurs de 2011 à 2017
le président du Conseil général de
Maine-et-Loire 2004 à 2011 et de députés
européens de 2009 à 2011 donc nous leur
avons demandé à tous les à tous vos
prédécesseurs depuis les 10 dernières
années le tirait un bilan de la
politique publique de rénovation
énergétique des freins qu'ils ont pu
constater et des améliorations
préconisées pour améliorer à la fois
l'efficacité de cette politique et le
pilotage au niveau ministériel mais
aussi au niveau administratif donc
j'aimerais également avoir votre réponse
à cette question à l'exception
naturellement peut-être du bilan
puisqu'effectivement vous venez de toute
façon assez récente de prendre vos
responsabilités ministérielles donc nous
avons entendu depuis le mois de février
également un grand nombre d'acteurs de
la rénovation énergétique et ce qui
ressortit très souvent de ces auditions
c'est le sujet de la confiance qui est
revenu à plusieurs reprises dans
l'ensemble de nos auditions face aux
fraudes face aux cuisson à l'instabilité
normative comment peut-on effectivement
redonner confiance dans la politique
publique de rénovation énergétique
seriez-vous favorable à une plus grande
mutualisation des contrôles de chantier
de rénovation ainsi qu'à une évolution
vers une conditionnalité des aides à des
contrôles aposériori le dispositif mon
accompagnateur rénove qui va se mettre
en place à partir du 1er septembre qui
permettra à des acteurs privés
d'accompagner les ménages dans leur
parcours de rénovation énergétique ne
risque-t-il pas de renforcer ce manque
de confiance ne faudrait-il pas plutôt
s'appuyer sur le réseau d'accompagnement
public existant qui revêt un gage de
neutralité évident et qui est très
souvent mise en place par les
collectivités
les personnes entendues nous ont
également soumis de nombreuses
propositions que pensez-vous de l'idée
d'une loi de programmation pluriannuelle
de la rénovation énergétique pour
permettre aux ménages mais aussi au
secteur de disposer d'une plus grande
visibilité vous avez été pendant de
nombreuses années élus locales comment
comptez-vous parvenir à une plus grande
association des collectivités et des
acteurs locaux à la mise en oeuvre des
politiques publiques de rénovation
énergétique aujourd'hui même les
antennes locales de Lana n'ont aucune
prise sur ma prime rénove pour aider nos
concitoyens qui sont souvent perdus ou
en attente de réponse et qui dit qui
risque donc de se décourager ne faut-il
pas également remettre les entreprises
artisanales de nos territoires au cœur
de cette politique en débloquant leur au
label RGE j'aimerais également que vous
reveniez sur le Conseil national de la
transition écologique le 22 mai dernier
qui était présidé par madame la Première
ministre durant lequel l'interdiction
des chaudières à gaz dans la lignée de
celle des chaudières au fioul a été
annoncée pourriez-vous revenir sur cette
mesure nous identifions deux potentiels
effets de bord d'une part une telle
mesure peut encourager le changement des
systèmes de chauffage au détriment de
l'isolation des logements d'autre part
une électrification accélérée des
chauffages interroge sur la capacité des
réseaux d'électricité à faire face à une
telle évolution quelle réponse
pouvez-vous apporter à ces deux craintes
enfin comment ne pas évoquer la réelle
déception à l'issue du Conseil national
de la refondation sur le logement au du
travail qui a été fourni par le groupe
consacré à la transition écologique des
logements
renouveler les annonces sur le
déploiements de France rénov et des
accompagnateurs rénov ou indiqués qu'une
mesure technique sur le prêt avant
rénovation dont pas plus d'une centaine
a dû être accordée à ce jour nous semble
vraiment peu de choses quand à porter le
nombre de rénovations performantes à 200
000 en 2024 grâce au renforcement de ma
prime rénov c'est bien mais c'est une
ambition sans garde de perspective quand
la stratégie nationale bas carbone en
programmé plus de 500 000 en moyenne et
700 000 dans les années à venir voilà
avant de vous laisser la parole pour
répondre à ses premières questions il me
revient de vous indiquer que cette
audition est diffusée
en direct et en différé sur le site
internet du Sénat et comme compte-rendu
sera publié mais je dois également vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête serait
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
d'amende à 100000 euros d'amende je vous
invite donc Monsieur le Premier Ministre
comme pour toute commission d'enquête a
prêté serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité a levé la main droite
et à dire je le jure
je le jure et bien je vous laisse la
parole monsieur le ministre avant que
notre rapporteur et nos collègues qui
assistent à l'audition puissent vous
poser un certain nombre de questions
complémentaires merci à vous merci
madame la Présidente merci
au président Gontard à ceux qui
participent cet après-midi à ces
auditions et on vous écoutant je me
demande si je vais vous infliger une
intervention si je vais pas tout de
suite répondre aux questions que vous me
posez c'est vous qui choisissez
à dérouler comme la sans doute fait
Agnès renacher qu'il y avait un avant et
un après que ma prime avait peut-être
des défauts mais que au moins ça va être
mérite d'exister que c'était quand même
un million 500 000 rénovations qui
avaient eu lieu qui avait des
dispositifs de lutte contre la fraude
qui s'était mis en place qui avait des
réflexions sur la manière dont
l'intensifier tout ça en 11 minutes
d'après la relecture qui a été faite par
mes équipes et donc si vous voulez bien
pour me concentrer sur les questions je
réponds peut-être pour que ce soit un
peu plus vivant sur la manière de
présenter les choses avec un propos
préalable qui sera très bref
d'abord je me réjouis que comprenne le
temps de se pencher sur ce qui est un
des principaux leviers de la
planification écologique
et si on se dit tout
on sait qu'on a un certain nombre de
transformation qui entraîne des
irritants parce que
elle conduisent à des changements de
comportement ou à des alourdissements de
frais qui fragilisent une partie de nos
concitoyens qui les interroge et qui les
font assimiler la transition écologique
à un prétexte pour augmenter les impôts
pour faire en sorte de restreindre un
certain nombre de liberté
la rénovation c'est sans doute le lieu
où on peut tout concilier quelque chose
qui est bon pour la planète qui est bon
pour l'emploi et pour les retomber
économiques et qui est bon également
pour le pouvoir d'achat en faisant en
sorte de diminuer une partie des
factures qui sont liées à ça et donc un
combat
aussi consensuel que les le
photovoltaïque en matière d'énergie
renouvelable non pas que je souhaite
pointer des domaines qui le seraient
moins là-dedans mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que nous savons que ce chemin de
la transition écologique il nécessite
une ampleur dans la baisse de nos
émissions et que certaines sont plus
irritantes que d'autres dans ce qu'elle
change ça veut pas dire que tout est
simple vous avez parlé des chaudières
gaz je vais évidemment répondre à votre
question mais ça veut dire qu'on sent
bien que là il y a un domaine dans
lequel on peut faire en sorte que la
transition écologique au sens large
ce soit pas seulement une occasion
d'affrontement mais que ce soit sans
doute une occasion de regroupement et je
pense qu'on approfondément besoin à bien
des égards
je veux dire ensuite que dans toute
cette politique de rénovation
énergétique dont nous allons parler il y
a un angle mort qui est celui des
bâtiments publics
on se concentre et c'est ça peut être
étonnant comme façon de commencer des
choses mais je tiens à le dire on a
globalement un dispositif qui a été
conçu pour les particuliers avec ses
avantages et ses défauts dont on va
discuter mais avec en tout cas le mérite
que avant il y avait rien ou très peu de
choses et on a globalement en parallèle
un milliard de mètres carrés qui abrite
des bâtiments tertiaires dans ce
milliard on en a environ 40% qui relève
des collectivités locales et de l'État
et on a à ce stade des dispositifs qui
sont également à faire monter en
puissance en termes de rénovation
énergétique on s'aperçoit que c'est la
première cause de demande de fond vert à
l'échelle des collectivités locales je
peux vous donner le chiffre le plus
actualisé lundi nous étions à 12116
dossiers déposés au titre du fond vert
et dans cela on en avait environ 4800
qui portaient sur de la rénovation
thermique de bâtiments vous ajoutez à ça
un peu plus de 2000 sur les réseaux
d'éclairage public et vous avez un bon
50% des collectivités
déposer des dossiers qui se concentrent
sur ce que ça pourrait permettre de
générer en termes d'économie le tiers
financement est une première réponse et
le texte qui a été voté à l'unanimité du
Sénat et de l'assemblée qui a maintenant
fait l'objet de décrète publication
depuis quelques jours on est en train
d'essayer dans tirer un mode
d'application simplifié pour les
collectivités locales en faisant
travailler le céréma sur une sorte de
fiche type sur la manière dont ça
fonctionne et on va réunir quelques
collectivités très diverses un
département pour les collèges une ville
pour plusieurs communes pour plusieurs
bâtiments de manière à beta tester si
j'ose dire le dispositif est regarder
comment ce levier complémentaire au
dispositif et aux aides pour être mis en
place
une fois que j'ai dit ça
il faut évidemment avoir une vision de
ma prime rénov et ne pas oublier que
derrière les dispositifs collectifs
comme le font chaleur de la dame
permettent aussi indépendamment de tous
les gestes qui sont posés par un certain
nombre de particuliers de pouvoir
proposer des solutions d'évolution
d'évolution énergétique qui sont
puissantes et qui peuvent permettre en
plus de conduire une politique qui soit
à la fois écologique et sociale et comme
vous avez eu d'amabilité de retracer mon
parcours une des vraies fiertés que j'ai
eu ça a été le lancement de deux réseaux
de chaleur dans les deux quartiers
politiques de la ville sur lesquels nous
faisions le tram en profitant des trous
dans les rues causés par l'arrivée des
rails pour poser des canalisations
permettant dans un quartier à 66% de
logements sociaux et un quartier à 52%
de logements sociaux de pouvoir
bénéficier de résoudre ce type
vous m'avez posé un certain nombre de
questions précises et je vais faire en
sorte d'y répondre autant que possible
je commence peut-être par le plus
stratégique dans vos questions c'est à
dire l'intérêt qui aurait à bénéficier
d'une loi de programmation plus réelle
de la rénovation
nous avons
une
stratégie nationale bas carbone qui est
complétée par une programmation plus
annuelle de l'énergie dans cette
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
la loi de programmation énergique climat
doit comporter un volet sur la
rénovation énergétique et donc plutôt
qu'une loi de programmation proprement
dit je pense que le Parlement doit
s'assurer qu'à l'intérieur de la loi de
programmation énergie climat cette
dimension et bien prise en compte le
rapport Pisany ferry et d'ailleurs très
explicite sur le fait que dans les
domaines sur lesquels il y aura de
l'argent public à mobiliser dans les
années qui viennent la question de la
rénovation sera l'un d'entre eux et donc
il y aurait une vraie logique parce que
dans la continuité de tous ces rapports
on fasse en sorte d'aller dans la lpec
s'assurer qu'il y a une déclinaison
et je le relie à la question des
chaudières
pour se dire les choses de façon on n'a
pas fini de faire parler
qui va commencer à faire parler jusqu'au
28 juillet ce qui a été interdit ce qui
est pardon lapsus total mais parce que
la façon dont vous avez posé la question
sur l'interdiction ce qui a été posé
c'est le fait de lancer le débat et la
concertation sur les perspectives que
nous avions si on se dit les choses là
aussi sans trop les simplifier
nous sommes globalement après avoir
enregistré des chiffres du cité pas sur
nos émissions carbone au titre de
l'année 2022 un peu plus de 25% de
baisse de nos émissions par rapport à
1990 c'est à dire que le chemin qui nous
reste à parcourir il est équivalent à
celui qu'on a déjà fait les -55% moins
50% des missions plus 5% de stockage un
horizon 1990 suppose de doubler le
rythme pour tenir en 2030 cette ambition
la planification c'est prendre des 408
millions de tonnes que nous avons au 1er
janvier c'est regarder les 270 millions
de tonnes que nous auxquelles nous
devons être à la fin de l'année 2030 et
c'est de se demander comment on va aller
chercher ses 538 millions de tonnes
secteur par secteur
et je ne sais pas si ce travail vous a
été présenté y compris dans sa vision
globale avec les différents tableaux
mais les 30% qui sont liés au secteur
des transports les 20% des 20% sur
l'agriculture les 20% sur l'industrie
les 20% sur les bâtiments au sens large
font donc l'objet d'un détail quand on
regarde ce détail on s'aperçoit que ce
qui est majeur aujourd'hui dans les
émissions du secteur je parle bien hors
construction
ce sont les émissions qui sont liées aux
énergies fossiles le gaz
beaucoup le fioul énormément
tenir la trajectoire ça veut dire
globalement être en capacité de baisser
de manière continue le nombre de
chaudières fioules dans ce pays et de ce
point de vue le mécanisme est enclenché
on est en gros puis le milieu du dernier
quinquennat sur entre 180 et 200 000
remplacements de chaudière par an pour
tenir le rythme fixé par la
planification il faudrait être aux
alentours de 300 000 ce qui nous semble
pas du tout inatteignables la question
de la chaudière gaz elle est différente
d'abord vous pointez de risques j'en
ajoute un troisième au risque de vous
surprendre vous citez le sujet de
attention à ce qu'on se retrouve pas
avec des gens qui ne se préoccupent plus
d'isolation mais qui se concentre sur le
mode de chauffage et deuxièmement dans
quelle mesure notre système électrique
va être capable de faire face il y en a
un troisième on est plutôt bon en
matière d'installation de chaudière gaz
et production
les pompes à chaleur
sont en matière de chauffage ce que les
voitures électriques sont aux voitures
thermiques c'est-à-dire avec une
domination aujourd'hui chinoise sur une
partie de ce secteur à une nuance près
c'est qu'on a d'excellents fabriquants
en particulier dans l'Est de la France
qui sont en train de monter en puissance
et de monter en gamme
qu'on a déjà une filière européenne en
particulier polonaise qui est
relativement forte mais je ne vous
invite à intégrer
dès la planification écologique de
l'évolution des chaudières gaz ce que
nous sommes en train de faire pour les
voitures en nous disant qu'il faudra
sans doute modifier certains critères
et ça c'est évidemment un enjeu personne
ne peut contester le fait que si on veut
baisser nos émissions il faut qu'on
diminue la part de gaz naturel dans nos
maisons
en revanche on sait qu’on a quelques
angles morts 1 les bâtiments collectifs
à partir d'une certaine puissance la
pompe à chaleur ou la biomasse ne suffit
pas il nous faut une part de gaz et je
pense que samedi pour que le biogaz ne
soit pas exclu d'une équation parce
qu'on en a besoin et on se rend compte
dans le mix énergétique qu'on a besoin
et il faut faire preuve d'humidité y
compris avec l'hiver qu'on a vécu de la
hauteur de la marche via
l'électrification elle est forte ça doit
nous rappeler deux choses les
changements de motorisation des
changements d'énergie ne doivent pas
nous faire oublier que sobriété et
efficacité énergétique sont toujours les
premiers leviers sur lesquels il faut
jouer et donc paradoxalement par rapport
à ce que vous disiez isolez un logement
pour faire en sorte de diminuer la
quantité d'énergie dont on a besoin et
toujours quelque chose de pertinent
avant de se retrouver dans une situation
de changement de chaudière
de manière justement à ne pas trop tirer
sur le sur le secteur
vous avez ensuite
évoqué mon accompagnateur rénove l'appui
des collectivités locales
dans ce domaine j'assume une vision qui
consiste à dire que je pense qu'il faut
aller plus loin dans la décentralisation
ou la déconcentration moi ma conviction
c'est que sur le modèle de la délégation
des aides à la pierre qui fonctionnent
ou l'état transfert les crédits et les
objectifs
nous gagnerions à nous appuyer sur les
collectivités qui seraient volontaires
pour faire en sorte de mettre en oeuvre
ma prime manœuvre
je ne dis pas que c'est une position qui
est partagée par tout le monde mais
j'assume pleinement que pour la cohésion
des territoires et la transition
écologique que je représente je pense
que le maire ou le président
d'intercommunalité parce qu'il est
vraisemblable qu'il ne faille pas
descendre à un niveau municipal pour une
compétence de ce type et le tiers de
confiance qui peut à la fois rassurer
celui qui va chercher le type d'aide
dont il peut bénéficier pour rénover son
logement qui peut fiabiliser le
processus de recrutement des
accompagnateurs parce que on peut être
certain qu'il veillera à ce que ceux qui
sont enregistrés dans une commune d'une
taille humaine ne soit pas des
margoulins et soit des gens qui soient
en capacité effective de pouvoir
accompagner leurs concitoyens voir
parfois considérer que une part de
service public peut remplacer ou
accompagner ce qui se fait et il y aura
une tendance naturelle pour tenir les
objectifs ou à rajouter un peu de moyens
ou à faire en sorte d'assurer davantage
de communication pour que le truc
fonctionne
la délégation des aides à la pierre
aujourd'hui elle fonctionne avec un
double standard la possibilité d'une
prise de compétence départementale et la
possibilité pour les agglomérations de
plein droit de demander la compétence et
le fait qu'on puisse avoir les deux
systèmes qui cohabitent dans certains
départements ou des endroits au
contraire dans lesquels aucun des deux
niveau de collectivité n'a pris la
responsabilité je pense que ce serait un
bon système qui nous permettrait de
réaliser une partie de la quadrature du
cercle sur ce dispositif et qui répond à
la manière dont vous avez présenté les
choses sur le fait de savoir si le
réseau public ne serait pas plus
efficace que celui des accompagnateurs
et dans quelle mesure les collectivités
devaient s'engager
enfin vous avez évoqué la question de la
conditionnalité des aides je vais pas
dire qu'on est passé d'un standard à
l'autre mais on est passé globalement
d'un dispositif
où on traitait beaucoup d'aide et où
tout à coup on s'est demandé s'il n'y
avait pas un risque de Frau d'important
un dispositif dans lequel la mise en
place d'un certain nombre de contrôle a
conduit à allonger des délais de
paiement et à justifier une forme
d'insatisfaction
je pense que la confiance de nos
concitoyens dans le dispositif
et majeur et je préfère avoir un délai
de paiement un peu plus long mais
l'assurance qui a pas de fraude plutôt
que de me retrouver rattrapé par une
autre patrouille sur le fait que nous
aurignoter un conséquent avec les
données publiques de quoi parlons-nous
on parle de délai qui sont globalement
aux alentours de 28 jours pour
l'attribution de la subvention
le 28 jours étant une moyenne et étant
moins long quand le dossier est
immédiatement complet et alors qu'on a
peu d'accompagnateurs et donc peu de
dossiers qui sont déposés par des tiers
ça n'est pas un mauvais score moyen même
si ça peut refléter des disparités
et là dessus on a peu bougé globalement
là où le délai s'est envolé c'est pour
le paiement
où nous étions globalement en août de
l'année dernière à un peu moins de 30
jours et nous sommes à 45 jours d'après
les derniers chiffres que j'ai en ma
possession qui date du mois d'avril
et encore j'ai pris la référence à août
parce que c'est le moment ou un certain
nombre de décision était prise dans la
continuité du rapport de l'IGF c'était
où tout septembre on l'a reçu mais
on était à un délai encore un peu plus
faible sur le délai de paiement quand
nous étions au printemps de l'année
dernière
néanmoins sur place
ils ont permis d'aller fiabiliser un
dispositif et ce qu'il faut payer
d'abord et faire en sorte de récupérer
l'argent après on s'aperçoit
malheureusement à l'usage que dans un
certain nombre de cas quand les choses
sont organisées une fois que vous avez
versé des crédits si ça n'est pas de
l'afro d'individuelle mais que c'est
dans le cadre d'un réseau c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué de retrouver l'argent une
fois qu'il a été versé donc je plaide
pour que le dispositif actuel soit
maintenu mais je pense que là aussi
la collectivité locale et le fait de
pouvoir avoir des délégations serait à
la fois un moyen de pouvoir expérimenter
des dispositifs sans le faire sur la
totalité du territoire national et de
pouvoir avoir une forme de recueil des
bonnes pratiques
enfin vous avez terminé me semble-t-il
par le Conseil national de la
refondation et par la manière dont hier
soir
ce conseil a été clôturé pour sa phase
de concertation
vous ne m'interrogez pas sur le logement
neuf et la situation globale de la
remontée des taux d'intérêt mais je l'ai
bien compris sur la partie plus
spécifique qui concerne nos ambitions de
rénovation et de planification
ce CNR j'ai lu beaucoup de choses
aujourd'hui à défaut d'avoir pu
participer hier
certains ont fait une sorte de
rendez-vous définitive sur ces questions
de logement alors que ça n'était qu'un
point d'État en particulier pour ce qui
concerne la planification il serait
baroque de prétendre faire les
conclusions définitives d'un sujet aussi
vaste que celui-là au milieu de tout les
évolutions que nous connaissons au début
du mois de juin alors que la
planification écologique globale est
prévue pour le début du mois de juillet
et qui en parallèle un certain temps de
rendez-vous dont un autre angle mort
qui est celui du logement social que
madame la Présidente vous connaissez
parfaitement et pour lequel vous savez
que on a un dispositif pour les
particuliers on a un dispositif dont
j'ai dit un mot et qui doit faire
l'objet d'une montée en puissance pour
les collectivités publiques et puis on a
ensuite la question plus large des
bailleurs sociaux
avec un parc moyen de ces bailleurs
sociaux qui est plutôt mieux entretenu
que le parc global
mais avec un sujet parce que un point de
livret A ça représente l'équivalent de
1,3 milliards d'euros de charges entre
guillemets sur les fonds propres somme
comparables d'ailleurs au coût de l'arns
mais la RLS c'est une fois le taux de
livret A c'est chaque point qui vaut ça
donc quand vous êtes dans la tendance
que nous connaissons on mesure l'impact
sur les fonds propres et quand vous le
couplez les augmentations sur les prix
des matériaux vous mesurez les
difficultés que nous avons
il faut donc au-delà de la question de
la production de logements que la
question de la rénovation ne l'oublie
pas parce que si on est sincèrement
convaincu par la transition écologique
1,5 millions de
bâtiments de logement vide dans ce pays
3 millions de mètres carrés de bureau
vide juste en ce moment
à Paris en Île-de-France et la question
d'un certain nombre de parcs de
bailleurs sociaux c'est nécessite qu'on
s'y occupe là le point de rendez-vous
c'est le pack de confiance avec les
bailleurs sociaux et un des principaux
leviers c'est sans doute le dispositif
de vie
qui est de considérer qu'à partir d'un
certain niveau de rénovation il serait
pas stupide de pouvoir réouvrir les
droits aux exonérations je dis pas qu'il
suffit parce qu'il a question des fonds
propres mais il permettrait y compris
intellectuellement de bien dire que on
redébre un agrément et c'est très
important y compris culturellement de de
gagner la bataille de la rénovation pour
ne pas se dire qu'il y a d'un côté ce
qui serait noble faire un logement neuf
et de l'autre côté ce qui serait une
forme de d'investissement au rabais qui
consisterait à investir dans la
rénovation donc il y a le sujet du
soutien à la production de logements
neuf qui est à corréler à plein d'autres
sujets mais il y a également le sujet de
la rénovation de manière plus spécifique
sur lequel on a un levier ça n'est pas
le seul je pourrais détailler si le cas
en particulier sur les durées des prêts
sur des quantités d'autres sujets sur
lesquels vous m'interrogerez peut-être
je m'arrête là parce que j'ai déjà été
long pour pour les réponses que je vous
ai faites mais ça valait réponses et
interventions de de démarrage
merci monsieur le ministre je vais sans
plus tarder laisser la parole au
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente
merci merci Monsieur ministre pour déjà
c'est ces éléments d'abord un point de
partage en tout cas sur sur ce que vous
avez dit sur la transition écologique
puisque c'est vrai que quand on s'y
engage et quand on y engage concrètement
c'est effectivement quelque chose qui
qui à la fois rassemble apporte des
solutions efficaces et puis c'est une
vraie réponse sociale et je dirais quel
que soit en tout cas sur les
orientations dans lequel on s'y engage
donc je pense qu'effectivement c'est
c'est vous avez eu raison de raison de
le rappeler
par rapport à ce que vous avez dit sur
sur l'ensemble de des dispositifs qui
ont été mis en place c'est vrai que j'ai
rappelé peut-être que cette commission
d'enquête son but était d'abord
justement de faire cette évaluation en
fait des politiques publiques depuis les
10 voire 15 dernières années pour voir
en fait justement à la fois comment
était utilisé l'argent public et
efficacité de cette de cet argent public
c'est vrai qu'on peut voir et on peut
distinguer puisque vous avez parlé des
collectivités effectivement des
bâtiments publics c'est que sur la
Commission on a volontairement pas exclu
parce que on a évidemment des liens mais
on sait vraiment concentré sur sur le
logement et c'était volontaire puisque
c'est déjà un sujet très vaste mais sur
le logement c'est vrai qu'on peut
distinguer en trois en trois blocs le
logement individuel privé ou
effectivement il y a le dispositif prime
rénov etc et tout ce parcours qui peut
être mis on a tout l'aspect copropriété
qui est du coup d'autres complications
en tout cas d'autres dispositifs sur
lequel il faut à la fois réfléchir et
puis vous venez d'en parler sur sur le
logement social et sur les bailleurs
sociaux où là on va dire on a et ça a
été rappelé aussi plutôt un secteur où
on est en avance en tout cas avec des
bâtiments qui sont plutôt déjà
pour la plupart en tout cas ont déjà
fait l'objet de rénovation et en un
secteur c'est peut-être ma première
question c'est vrai que sur logement
social on peut s'apercevoir que là on a
un levier très fort on a des opérateurs
on a des bailleurs qui nous disent très
clairement dans les auditions on est
prêt à tenir les objectifs
on veut les tenir on sait faire on a
cette expertise on a cette habitude et
qu'en plus quand on fait de la
rénovation thermique en plus c'est ça
permet d'améliorer globalement le
logement en termes de en termes de
confort en termes de l'espace
urbain etc et donc en fait le seul point
qui nous manque c'est l'argent et c'est
le financement et par rapport à ce qu'on
peut dire sur les deux autres parties
qui soient copropriété ou logement
individuel c'est vrai qu'on pourrait se
dire bah tiens ce secteur là est
peut-être un secteur assez facile parce
que là en injectant de l'argent en ayant
des financements beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus fort on pourrait du coup booster
très rapidement justement cette cette
rénovation thermique donc ma première
question c'est c'est justement pourquoi
pas peut-être plus prioriser justement
ce financement sur le logement le
logement social
ensuite sur sur les copropriétés
on abordant très rapidement mais c'est
vrai qu'on a vu les problématiques qui
pouvaient y avoir à la fois sur la prise
de décision donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
pas mal de choses de réflexion à avoir
sur la prise de décision sur sur les
copro et puis sur peut-être le type de
financement et puis la question du la
question du DPE est peut-être d'aller
vers un DPE plutôt collectif qui pose
qui permettrait de simplifier les choses
et qui permettrait justement d'accélérer
cette cette prise de décision et puis
après sur l'individuel on voit toute la
problématique alors c'est vrai qu'on
peut toujours voir le côté positif c'est
vrai que si on prend les chiffres de 600
à 700 000
prime rénov qui ont été débloqués
c'est oui plutôt sont plutôt positives
quand on regarde d'un peu plus près
c'est vrai vous l'avez dit on est plutôt
sur du changement de chaudière c'est un
aspect positif puisque ça fait tomber
très rapidement le les émissions de
carbone
donc ça c'est effectivement l'aspect
positif par contre on est très en deçà
des objectifs et on voit bien qu'on
pêche vraiment sur la rénovation globale
quoi et c'est peut-être là où on doit
réfléchir peut-être plus plus
précisément sur les dispositifs à mettre
à mettre en place et donc comment on va
plutôt faire en sorte que
que ce parcours là et ce qu'on
s'aperçoit c'est à la fois de rendre ce
parcours un peu plus simple la question
des collectivités locales vous en avez
vous en avez parlé mais c'est vrai que
on entend on entend ce ce discours et de
dire il faut s'appuyer sur ce qui existe
et sur les collectivités locales c'est
vrai que dans les différentes auditions
et dans les différents retours qu'on a
eu on a un sentiment quand même de la
part des collectivités le calque celle
dont sa fonctionné qui avait mis des
choses en place ou un peu l'impression
de devoir recommencer de devoir se
réadapter et parfois d'être un peu
court-circuit quoi donc vouloir comment
notamment sur
l'accompagnateur Renov
on va voir du coup quelle forme
réellement il prend mais c'est vrai
qu'on avait que ça soit les plateformes
de rénovation que ce soit des Alecs ou
on avait de l'ingénierie qui était mis
qui était mis en place puis on vient du
coup reposer cet accompagnateur Renov
qui peut avoir un intérêt mais on vient
rajouter une une
ingénierie et donc ça peut être perçu de
la part des collectivités soit de se
dire bon bah c'est plus la peine que je
le fasse je laisse ça
ou alors en tout cas de ce chevauchement
en tout cas qui peut y avoir et puis
l'autre aspect c'est quand même la
question du financement des
collectivités locales et c'est vrai que
si on veut avoir des plateformes de
rénovation et si on va avoir de
l'ingénierie locale ça veut dire du coup
des budgets de fonctionnement qui vont
forcément augmenter en lien avec ça et
donc ça ça pose aussi cette question là
de comment on prend cette prise en
compte en fait de l'augmentation des
budgets de fonctionnement dans la
réalité en lien avec la rénovation la
rénovation thermique et plus
généralement avec la transition avec la
transition écologique donc voilà du coup
il y avait peut-être cette aspect là sur
les sur les collectivités sur comment on
arrive mieux à plaquer en fait ce
dispositif et mieux s'adapter localement
parce que ça ça paraît être quelque
chose de quelque chose d'important et
puis ensuite peut-être pour terminer et
puis laisser la place à mes collègues
s'ils ont d'autres d'autres questions
peut-être un avis sur le sur le pilotage
puisqu'on a vu votre collègue juste
avant sur la transition énergétique
comment enfin peut-être votre perception
ou votre avis sur le pilotage national
de la rénovation énergétique et
peut-être la coordination qui peut y
avoir entre les différents ministères on
va on va aussi auditionner le ministre
du Logement et c'est vrai que quand on a
auditionné
les anciens les anciens ministres
souvent nous a fait part justement de ce
lien entre le ministère du Logement
ministère de l'écologie qui avait son
importance et donc comment vous voyez
vous voyez cette cette coordination et
donc peut-être comment on pourrait
l'améliorer et puis également peut-être
votre bilan sur le la coordination
interminale du plan de rénovation qui a
été mis en place et de savoir voilà ce
que le bilan vous en tirez est-ce que
vous pensez que justement que dans son
action est suffisante justement pour
coordonner l'ensemble des politiques au
niveau des différents ministères merci
très bien d'abord
la liaison avec ce que j'ai pu dire à la
présidente Estrosi ça sonne sur les
bailleurs sociaux
on a un bailleur qui a finalisé son plan
global de décarbonation
qui est évidemment une puissance de feu
qui est pas comparable à tous les
bailleurs de ce pays mais c'est Action
Logement et qui va avoir l'occasion de
détailler la manière dont ils envisagent
de tenir compte de tout ça c'est pas
neutre c'est quand même 30% du parc
social ça a un impact et de manière
générale quel que soit les domaines
c'est toujours bien d'avoir des exemples
qu'ensuite on est capable de suivre pour
pouvoir étalonner les éléments
et je le dis parce que ça veut dire
qu'on parle pas de rien et je voudrais
aussi rendre hommage à des quantités
d'office détenus par des élus locaux qui
ont pas forcément attendu d'avoir une
cathédrale qui soit complète pour aller
lancer des opérations des mères qui ont
fixé des objectifs à leur bailleur qui
ont fait en sorte d'aller accompagner
les différents dispositifs je partage
d'abord
l'idée que
c'est un moyen de faire en sorte d'avoir
des résultats qui peuvent être rapides
on le sait une des difficultés c'est que
ma prime rénov en moyenne fonctionne
mieux dans de la maison individuelle la
copropriété ralentit une partie de la
prise de décision
et là on a des copropriétés où je n'ai
pas le la principale difficulté pour
faire des travaux dans la copropriété
c'est à dire besoin de l'unanimité des
propriétaires puisque la plupart du
temps il y a une unité de décision
quelques cas très particuliers
deuxièmement par rapport au débat que
nous avions juste auparavant la part du
gaz
dans les logements sociaux
et plus importante puisque en gros on a
quatre logements sur 10 qui sont
chauffés au gaz et la proportion elle
dépasse les 6 sur 10 quand on est dans
le parc social
et avec une capacité à ne pas avoir les
mêmes inquiétudes sur le reste à charge
sur la manière d'avancer quand on se
retrouve dans cette situation et
généralement là aussi la pertinence de
réseau de chaleur urbain ou de
dispositifs de ce type qui peuvent
permettre d'aller alimenter d'aller
participer à une visibilité des prix et
donc aussi un impact social des
décisions qui sont prises
on a une double articulation à avoir
une articulation financière parce qu'on
a cet enjeu particulier de son propre
dans le contexte dans lequel nous sommes
en n'oubliant pas qu'il s'agit d'aller
entretenir un parc et donc
que ça s'inscrit aussi dans les dans les
obligations de ces bailleurs mais on a
cette difficulté conjoncturelle qui
ajoute
et qui nécessite de trouver le chemin je
vais pas aller beaucoup plus loin
aujourd'hui puisque vous savez la nature
des discussions et que y compris ça va
être au cœur de mes discussions dans les
prochains jours en particulier avec
l'USH
pour pour arriver à trouver la manière
de signer ce pack de confiance autour de
cet enjeu de la rénovation dans quelques
dans quelques semaines
je veux juste dire un mot sur
monogest contre global
on est tous d'accord sur le fait
qu'évidemment c'est mieux de faire
plusieurs gestes plutôt qu'un seul
je ne sais pas ce que j'aurais fait si
j'avais été amené à concevoir le
dispositif et j'ai trop d'humilité pour
me mettre à la place de ce qui était en
charge à l'époque parce qu'il était pas
certain qu'on mesurait qui aurait
beaucoup de Quick Queen et peu de
dispositifs qui iraient plus loin je
veux juste donner un chiffre c'est que
c'est quand même en moyenne
793 euros d'économie de factures pour
ceux qui ont conduit ces opérations ce
qui est pas rien du tout pour beaucoup
de pour beaucoup de gens et une vraie
réussite sur le ciblage social donc on a
certainement des choses qui sont à
améliorer pour en avoir davantage pour
un autre argent d'un point de vue
climatique mais il faut en parallèle ne
pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain si
j'ose dire
parce que ça enclenché une dynamique qui
fait que maintenant se demande comment
on l'améliore comment on fait en sorte
de l'approfondir mais qu'elle mérite
d'exister parce qu'on avait peu de
choses auparavant et c'est la limite que
je fais avec les Alecs ou un certain
nombre de choses c'est le jour et la
nuit en termes d'échelle en terme de
montrant en termes de de dispositifs
financiers en termes de suivi là où vous
avez raison c'est que on pourra pas
transférer ça au collectivités locales
en vous disant débrouillez-vous et ce
n'est pas le sens de ma proposition
ce que je dis
c'est que au cœur de discussion que
nous pouvons avoir en matière de
logement
s'il y a bien des choses qui seraient
pertinentes de décentraliser c'est des
compétences qui touchent le logement
parce que les situations sont très
disparaître d'un endroit à l'autre
c'est vrai
pour la rénovation mais ça peut l'être
dans d'autres domaines est-ce que les
zonages doivent forcément être
déterminés depuis Paris est-ce que les
expériences du Pinel breton permettant
par exemple y compris demain d'imaginer
des dispositifs de soutien à l'opération
sont pas des choses qui pourraient
s'imaginer plutôt que d'avoir quelque
chose dont je salue la fin parce que le
dispositif n'était pas suffisamment
ciblé il avait un mérite de soutien à la
promotion mais globalement quant à la
fin vous encouragez plutôt une
acquisition à Saint-Gilles-Croix-de-Vie
que dans une zone tendue
je ne suis pas sûr que ni d'un point de
vue social ni d'un point de vue
climatique là aussi on en avait pour
notre argent ça permettait de soutenir
un effort de construction mais qui avait
sans doute un besoin d'évolution du
ciblage
vous évoquez ensuite la question de du
pilotage de la coordination et du
dispositif le simple fait que vous soyez
amené à recevoir trois d'entre nous dans
le cadre de cette commission
que j'ai essayé mentalement de faire de
tête la liste de tous ceux qui depuis
2012 c'était un titre un autre succédé
dans cette responsabilité et que du coup
ça a dû beaucoup vous occuper permet de
mesurer qu'il y a évidemment des marges
d'amélioration dans ce domaine je plaide
juste pour le fait que on passe d'un
système à l'autre et que dans la
création de ce système il y a aussi des
choses qu'on est en train de tester et
de faire atterrir et il y a à la fois
une organisation qui est particulière
dans lequel
le président de la République est la
première ministre ont souhaité d'avoir
un ministère de la transition écologique
qui englobe des secteurs très émetteurs
transport et logement qui ont des
grandes latitudes dans beaucoup de
domaines mais qui peuvent être rattachés
sur des questions de planification ce
qui me vaut le plaisir d'être ici
aujourd'hui
et je pense que ça n'est pas une bêtise
d'avoir un ministère de la transition
écologique qui a en lien direct auprès
de lui des ministères qui sont très
émetteurs parce que ça permet d'avoir
une forme d'unicité dans la vision et
dans la planification et que d'autre
part le contexte que nous connaissons
depuis quelques mois avec la volatilité
des prix de l'énergie et la hauteur de
la marche sur l'électrification sur la
nécessité l'urgence de la relance de
notre programme nucléaire de
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables justifie pleinement
d'avoir un ministre une ministre en
l'espèce qui soit en charge de ces
questions
il y a un coordinateur gouvernemental il
y a des contacts qui sont constants et
il faut qu'on mesure qui a sans doute
besoin de davantage de coordination et
que le pilotage de la transition
écologique au sens large
et forcément collectif
la preuve c'est que je vous ai
j'ai presque convoqué Roland Lescure et
la question de l'industrie et la
question de la fabrication des pompes à
chaleur dans la discussion qu'on est en
train d'avoir de la même manière que
dans les transports se contenter de la
vision qui oublierait les constructeurs
automobiles ou les collectivités locales
qui sont gestionnaires de réseau de
transport de proximité les régions sur
les TER y compris la responsabilité
d'aller faire les pistes cyclabs qui
permettent à la fin de favoriser de
multiplier l'essor des mobilités actives
on est par définition très imbriquée sur
ces sujets et donc il faut une logique
parfois de chef de fila ou de chef
d'orchestre mais on ne peut pas résumer
leur caisse de la rénovation énergétique
à une personne ce n'est pas possible et
c'est pas l'histoire du contexte dans
lequel dans lequel nous sommes
globalement
en tout cas c'est ce que je pense y
compris parce qu'on a besoin de
partenaires j'ai évoqué l'ADEME qui en
est un mais il y en a d'autres
je laisse la parole à Franck Montauger
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre
présentation
je vous ai écouté attentivement
quelle forme concrète pour prendre
la planification aux différents niveaux
que vous avez évoqué jusqu'au niveau
territorial des communes ou des ou des
EPCI est-ce que vous avez dans l'idée
de contractualiser avec ces différents
niveaux échelons territorial par rapport
aux objectifs qui doivent être atteints
sur le territoire
égard à la question évidemment du
logement et à d'autres aspects que vous
venez de d'évoquer à l'instant en
précisant les choses je peux je vous je
partage tout à fait votre propos là
dessus voilà comment les choses vont se
traduire
concrètement
pour les responsables des différents
échelons territoriaux voire
départementaux régionaux
et et
nationaux voilà ça c'est ma première
question
deuxième question
peut-être plus plus technique
est-ce que vous considérez que pour
atteindre les objectifs
nationaux et respecter les trajectoires
que l'on s'est donné pour y parvenir
on possède toute la matière
voilà est-ce que est-ce que le contenu
du plan d'action si on dit les choses
simplement
il est il est aujourd'hui cerné sur les
différentes thématiques qui qui
impactent qui ont un effet sur les
objectifs à atteindre merci
alors je commence par planification
écologique et pardon
planification écologique et collectivité
territoriale j'ai réuni toutes les
associations des lieux le 11 mai dernier
et je leur ai présenté avec le sgpe la
feuille de route globale de la
planification en leur disant il va
falloir maintenant qu'on trouve le
contexte pour atterrir parce que la
vérité c'est que dans la moitié des
cases c'est vous
dans certaines vous avez besoin d'argent
dans d'autres vous avez besoin de
délégation de compétences dans une
troisième il faut qu'on discute je vous
donne un exemple très simple par exemple
représentant de l'Association des Maires
sur la partie stockage de carbone en
disant aidez-nous à défendre les haies à
pouvoir les sanctuariser dans le cadre
des plans locaux d'urbanisme parce que
on les subventionne on sait que
les S c'est une forme de forêt en termes
de stockage sauf que si ensuite on n'a
pas les moyens de s'opposer à une
opération de démembrement ou de
remembrement on n'a pas le levier qui
nous permet de préserver un
investissement qu'on a fait qui
s'inscrit dans une stratégie
planification vous allez considérer sur
le plan national qu'il faut faire x km
par an 2
donc le monde de l'agriculture est parti
prenante du sujet quand même bien sûr je
vous témoigne de ce que me dit la MF ça
ne veut pas dire que ça se fait en
opposition aux affaires ou aux Chambres
d'agriculture qui dans beaucoup de cas
sont exactement sur la même ligne pour
avoir eu l'occasion et quelques jours
d'échanger avec Marc feno non seulement
ici au pose pas mais il se demande même
comment on pourrait préserver le fait
d'avoir trop d'aller-retours sur ces
sujets mais je voulais pas ouvrir un
débat sur les je voulais vous donner cet
exemple pour montrer qu'il est
systématique et qui va plus loin à titre
totalement personnel
je pense que les certeux pour être la
bonne échelle de planification on a un
peu plus de 1000 ça permet d'avoir un
territoire avec lequel sur lequel on
pourrait discuter de ses ambitions
planification et faire en sorte de les
décliner dans les différents domaines
parce que les exemples que j'ai donné la
rénovation c'est évidemment un levier
très important mais on aura besoin des
collectivités sur le transport on aura
besoin des collectivités pour le
stockage quand on propose d'aller
soutenir de la renaturation ou des îlots
de fraîcheur c'est rien d'autre aussi
que de faire en sorte on aura besoin
d'elle sur la lutte contre l'étalement
urbain j'aurais le grand bonheur de voir
le groupe Europe Écologie Les Verts en
sortant de cette audition pour discuter
du texte qui arrive au Sénat en
commission la semaine prochaine et dans
l'hémicycle dans 15 jours le chemin qui
permet de tenir compte de ce que vous
avez dit sur le besoin d'assouplir et de
rendre le dispositif applicable et en
même temps de tenir un objectif de
division par deux de la consommation il
est crucial pour tenir la ligne de la
planification écologique au sens large
et je pense qu'il y a des marges par
exemple que dans les impensés plus
exactement
euh dans ce que nous n'avons pas eu le
temps d'évoquer il y aura la question de
la fiscalité d'usage c'est-à-dire qu'à
un moment si on veut faire en sorte
d'aller vers ça il faudra aussi qu'on
donne les moyens aux maires de renchérir
le coût de l'artificialisation parce
qu'on peut pas seulement raisonner en
combien d'argent public il faut qu'on
mette pour des polluer les frites
si ça coûte toujours plus cher de nous
attaquer au friche que de faire en sorte
de pouvoir limiter une partie de
l'impact je vais même aller plus loin
tant pis pour le cadre je pense qu'il
faudrait baisser la taxe sur le foncier
non bâti
si vous tenez compte du fait qu'on aura
globalement une agriculture qui devra se
passer d'une partie des intrants qui va
faire face à des difficultés de
ressources plus le niveau de l'impôt est
fort plus c'est une incitation aller
vers des rendements qui sont élevés donc
sans être dans une logique de
décroissance si on veut tenir compte du
fait que les choses sont complexes et
soutenir une agriculture de production
qui permet de favoriser les produits
courts je pense qu'il serait pas stupide
qu'on ait des réflexions aussi sur des
évolutions sur ce foncier nom bâti je
pense que tout le chantier de la
transition fiscale et la manière dont on
le connecteur à ces CRPE il est devant
nous
je pense qu'on pourra pas continuer par
exemple uniquement à raisonner de
manière française sur la question des
poids lourds qui viennent sur une partie
de notre territoire et qui comme il ne
paie pas la TICPE qui s'est rassuré
l'entretien des infrastructures ne
participent pas au financement de la
décarbonation qui est rendu possible par
l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport
je veux pas ouvrir tous les débats je
veux juste te dire que quand on commence
à tirer le fil de la planification et
des collectivités on va effectivement
faire en sorte d'ouvrir ça je crois au
CRPE et je crois au fond vert en en
faisant un vrai bilan et idéalement
évidemment on en augmentant les le
montant pour le connecter à ses projets
il a des défauts certainement il faudra
qu'on vérifie qu'il y a pas eu trop
d'applications disparaître sur le
territoire enfin le montant de crédit
demandé 4,2 milliards d'euros générant
17 milliards d'euros d'investissements
dans la transition écologique au sens
large c'est à dire exactement ce que les
think flank expliquent comme étant la
hauteur de la marche qu'il faudrait que
les collectivités assurent ça permet
d'avoir une petite idée des effets de
levier qu'on peut jouer ensuite c'est
aussi un angle nouveau dans lequel on
fait confiance aux collectivité locale
en mettant les crédits en demandant
ensuite au préfet de regarder quelle est
la bonne porte sur la biodive sur la
rénovation et en ne faisant pas autant
de portes qu'il y a de sujets avec trop
de dossiers
mais je pense que ce message de
confiance en a besoin parce que c'est
celui qui en plus permet de s'approprier
ces enjeux de transition au niveau de
nos concitoyens et je n'évacue pas la
question du fonctionnement
est-ce que dans une certaine mesure sur
les pcaet sur les dispositifs de soutien
sur lesquels il y a des besoins
d'ingénierie on mesure pas qu'il peut y
avoir un besoin d'ingénierie spécifique
c'est une certitude est-ce qu'elle doit
passer par la NCT par les agences par
français par les opérateurs de l'état où
est-ce qu'elle doit prendre la forme
d'un soutien en direct
là il y a des chemins dont on peut
discuter mais sur cette réalité je crois
à ça et ce qu'on a tout bien sûr que non
vous savez moyenne chose qui me frappe
c'est la capacité de s'investir dans un
hémicycle un peu moins ici plutôt qu'à
l'Assemblée
nettement moins en faisant comme si
c'était scandaleux que tout n'aille pas
plus vite qu'on me cite un pays au monde
qui aujourd'hui en termes de lutte
contre les règlements climatiques à
trouver le bon tempo
la vérité c'est qu'à part peut-être le
Costa Rica dans un contexte très
différent avec une taille de pays très
différente c'est pas comme si il y avait
un exemple à l'échelle de la peine qu'on
peut suivre dans certains domaines les
pays font mieux que nous dans certains
c'est nous qui faisons mieux que et
aujourd'hui tout le monde cherche le
chemin
le gouvernement allemand avec des
écologistes vient d'autoriser 144
projets routiers au grand dames de son
éleveur mais en expliquant qu'il fallait
tenir compte d'une partie du social et
de temporiser sur la partie gaz là où
vous avez un calendrier qui était assez
ambitieux pour aller vers une diminution
du parc je donne cet exemple
l'Angleterre
bien des égards n'est pas un exemple est
un modèle en matière d'éolien offshore
où ils sont vraiment réussis sous
l'impulsion de Boris Johnson aller très
loin il y a des exemples dont on peut
s'inspirer dans les pays scandinaves
mais il n'y a pas aujourd'hui la matrice
de ce qui conviendrait de suivre et les
pays dans lesquels il y a des
écologistes en responsabilité ne font
pas en moyenne mieux que ceux dans
lesquels il n'y en a pas quand on
regarde la situation dans laquelle on se
trouve je le dis pas pour autre chose
que pour nous dire ayant de l'humilité
en se disant pas que toutes les
solutions sont sur la table qu'on
m'enverra pas surgir certaines aussi
dans les semaines et dans les mois qui
viennent et qu'il faut pas qu'on
continue à pouvoir s'inspirer de ce qui
est autour de nous
je suis un peu étonné de la réponse que
vous faites là parce que moi je trouve
que sur ce sur ce sujet il y a beaucoup
de données scientifiques y compris de
recherche scientifiques et que les les
phénomènes et les impacts sont de mieux
en mieux cernés moi je me pose aussi
cette question là par rapport à la à la
mobilisation des acteurs concernés des
parties prenantes concernées dont les
territoires je pense qu'il faut
fixer peut-être de manière non
contraignante et de manière indicative
des objectifs clairs qui sont qui
peuvent être relatifs aux consommations
d'énergie en trajectoire évidemment en
diminution
et en tonne équivalent en carbone par
exemple économisé voilà où en émission
en émission carbone toujours en termes
de trajectoire il faut des choses
parlantes il faut des choses parlantes
pour pour les les élus qui vont être à
une charge de faire vivre ces contrats
et de mener l'action mais c'est tout
autant utile et si ce n'est plus pour
les citoyennes et les citoyens français
il y a une il y a une nécessité de de
d'embarquer tout le monde dans cette
affaire là qui est absolument
fondamentale quand elle a réussi
finalement du plan voilà c'était un peu
le sens
de la question que je vous posais par
rapport aux données aux indicateurs
finalement qui nous serviront aussi à
faire le suivi de l'action de son
efficacité comprenez le en fait je
réalise que j'ai compris votre question
comme étant la suite de la planification
au sens large et du dialogue global avec
les élus tous secteurs confondus mais en
revenant sur la rénovation
bien sûr il y a plein de données d'abord
on a toutes les données qui permettent
d'arrêter les pseudos débats sur le fait
de savoir s'il y a ou pas en dérèglement
climatique il y a juste pas de sujets il
est causé par l'homme je le dis parce
que vous voyez quand même encore des
persistances dans les discussions de
gens qui maintenant disent ok il y en a
un mais il est pas lié à l'homme c'est
un phénomène cyclique et naturel etc
bref
et je vous invite à lire le dernier
rapport de la Fédération Jean Jaurès sur
le complotisme et sur le pourcentage
d'adhésion à certains d'idées reçues
comme le fait que pour 41% des sondés
le dérèglement climatique sert de
prétexte pour restreindre des libertés
des peuples je vous dis juste ça parce
que je pense que ça pose aussi quelque
chose dans le schéma pour vous répondre
de manière précise
on a plein de données il y en a deux
trois qu'on peut fiabiliser je veux pas
esquiver le sujet du DPE vous savez que
un des indicateurs pour être capable
d'avoir le débat c'est que il peut
arriver faute de formation qu'on est des
écarts et normalement on devrait dans
les semaines qui viennent améliorer les
choses on a encore deux petits autres
sujets c'est quand même sur les petits
logements loi Carrez avec des poissons
les logements en altitude sur lequel des
données
scientifiques peuvent semer le trouble
quand vous expliquez la manière dont la
fin vous avez du mal à changer de classe
etc donc je dis ça je dis qu'on a un
deuxième sujet
qui est celui de se méfier de la
généralisation de certains processus qui
sont simples comme l'isolation par
l'extérieur notamment quand on est sur
des par exemple sur des maisons de
pleine pierre ou on peut avoir un sujet
qui conduit à se retrouver à faire de la
condensation à l'intérieur j'ai eu la
chance de discuter avec le président
Lafont et je le dis parce que parfois la
vision très globale sur mais on sait
comment on fait on le fait ailleurs etc
il faut quand même qu'on tienne compte
des matériaux qui sont utilisés de la
réalité du site sur lequel on se trouve
et un peu de parfois est nécessaire à
être introduite ensuite sur le fond
mon rêve c'est qu'on compte un carbone
mon rêve c'est qu'effectivement on soit
capable indépendamment des euros qu'on
soit en capacité de pouvoir présenter
des choses et je vais même plus loin mon
rêve en tant que ministre de la
transition écologique ce serait qu'un
jour la planification elle débouche sur
un budget carbone
sur un amendement dit recevabilité
climatique qui fait que vous ne pouvez
pas proposer quelques sortes d'article
40 il n'y a pas de lien avec l'actualité
à l'Assemblée nationale sur le sujet
mais qui permettent en substances de
considérer qu'un texte qui propose une
augmentation des émissions doit faire
l'objet d'une compensation d'une
justification qui soit solide de lever
le gage je pense qu'on aura un intérêt à
ne pas seulement avoir des chiffres qui
soient publiés tous les ans mais qui
puisse être publié tous les mois pour
qu'on s'aperçoive que en cours d'année
si on a des difficultés il faut faire
une sorte de budget climatique
rectificatif pour être capable d'aller
rechercher du carbone le monde n'a pas
trouvé donc dans ce domaine je suis tout
à fait prêt non pas dans le cadre de
cette compétition d'enquête mais dans un
autre à faire en sorte d'aller plus loin
sur ce qui me semble s'inscrire
là-dedans mais je partage Bason ça sur
la science avec des éléments objectifs
pas uniquement avec une comptabilité en
euros et en passant un pacte avec les
collectivités locales
merci alors la transition est presque
toute trouvée avec la question que va
vous poser Sabine dragsler
merci beaucoup alors oui monsieur le
ministre vous l'avez dit chez moi en
Alsace et ailleurs en France aussi quand
j'en parle avec mes collègues sénateurs
on se rend compte que notamment des
propriétaires bailleurs réalise des
travaux d'isolation et appliquent sur
des maisons en pierre ou alors des
maisons à Pont de Bois des techniques et
des matériaux qui sont complètement
inadaptés qui vont conduire à la à la
des altérations définitives de ce type
de bâti et là je quand je quand on parle
du patrimoine c'est pas uniquement le
patrimoine monumental moi je pensais aux
petits enfin au patrimoine résidentiel
en maison à colombages en Alsace au
petit hameau village dans le Massif
Central et en fait on ne peut pas en
vouloir c'est aux gens qui font ça parce
que je pense qu'il pense bien faire et
et beaucoup d'entre la majorité d'entre
eux ne sont pas informés des
caractéristiques qui sont propres à ce
type de bâti ou alors ce qu'on constate
également ce sont des gens qui renoncent
à faire les travaux parce que c'est trop
compliqué ou alors parce qu'ils n'ont
pas l'argent pour le faire et à ce
moment-là les maisons sont délaissées et
très vite se dégradent parce que des
maisons qui ne sont pas entretenues se
dégradent très vite et des promoteurs en
fait qui viennent les voir pour acquérir
les terrains et démolir ces maisons et
là j'ai vraiment peur qu'avec le zan on
va avoir une accentuation de ce type de
de phénomènes avec voilà ce que ça va
entraîner une banalisation de la France
et la disparition de son patrimoine bâti
alors hier on était au Parlement
européen Bruxelles et on nous a parlé du
d'une flexibilité qui serait possible
pour le patrimoine dans les directives à
venir alors je me posais la question de
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on estime être du
patrimoine de quel type de patrimoine
parle-t-on et je pense que c'est très
important de ne pas oublier ce petit
patrimoine qui fait la France et alors
je me posais la question de savoir s'il
fallait pas qu'on passe par une
identification de ce patrimoine et
peut-être une inscription dans les
documents d'urbanisme pour acter qu'ils
existent et qui sont là
alors ensuite j'avais une autre question
qui portait sur les matériaux
spécifiques à ce type de bâti donc des
matériaux biosourcés des matériaux
locaux des matériaux qui respirent
enfin qu'on utilisait quand on a
construit ses maisons alors j'aurais
aimé savoir on en était avec la question
des normes pour ce type de matériaux et
des questions à résoudre si on veut
pouvoir développer
l'isolation du bâti résidentiel ancien
avec ce avec ce type de matériaux et
enfin pour finir je me posais également
la question de savoir s'il faudrait
pouvoir s'accorder un temps pour créer
une espèce de DPE adaptés aux bâti
anciens qui prendrait en compte vraiment
les spécificités de ce type de bâti et
là je pense par exemple à l'inertie ou
au confort d'été
voilà merci
d'abord il me semble que vous avez
auditionné il y a quelques jours un
architecte des Bâtiments de France
Gabriel turquette Beauregard accompagné
de certaines associations issues de
patrimoine que j'ai moi-même reçu au
ministère pour faire en sorte d'avoir
une discussion et je vais pas redire
dans des termes moins
savant - érudit et moins appropriés que
lui ce qu'il a pu vous dire sur le sujet
le simple fait que je l'ai reçu et que
il m'est indiqué ce matin avoir été reçu
par vous et que j'allais recevoir
normalement à la fin de cette semaine
c'est préconisations sur les DPV sur le
bâti anciens sur les matériaux vous
permet de mesurer que c'est un sujet sur
lequel j'ai effectivement demandé pas
seulement parce qu'il est angevin et
donc on s'est connu dans ce cadre mais
que j'ai effectivement demandé à ce
qu'on m'aide à y voir plus clair et
éviter de trop normaliser les choses et
à tenir compte de cette spécificité
en particulier parce que l'isolation par
l'extérieur si c'est pour faire
disparaître nos façades ça pose une
difficulté et sans soulève d'autres y
compris dans des secteurs qui n'ont pas
forcément beaucoup d'intérêt
c'est l'impact éventuel que ça peut
avoir sur le rupture des alignements de
façade voir dans certains secteurs où on
a calculé les choses au plus juste parce
qu'on a hérité de rue qui était étroite
quelques conséquences sur les largeurs
qui sont disponibles par rapport à
d'autres obligations PMR je dis pas que
c'est la norme je dis juste qu'il faut
qu'on fasse très attention parce qu'à un
moment on se retrouve pas dans des
espèces de logique qui se qui se
poussent il y a une partie avec laquelle
je peux pas être en accord avec ce que
vous dites c'est parce que je trouve
qu'on
il ne faut pas faire porter aux ânes
tous les mots je crois vrai dire
exactement l'inverse je pense que si on
ne préserve pas notre patrimoine
naturelle on aura du mal à valoriser
notre patrimoine tout court
je pense que ce qui fait la beauté de
nombre de coins de France ça n'est pas
le plein c'est l'évite qu'on a été
capable de préserver et je ne suis pas
certain que les 40 dernières années soit
la plus grande contribution au génie du
patrimoine français contenu des formes
qui ont été faites et je veux même vous
dire je pense que les endroits qui sont
parfois les plus
noble ne sont pas les moins denses et
que des alignements de façades sont
parfois plus majestueux que des
pavillons entourés par des jardins de
1500 m² je comprends le souhait de
beaucoup de nos concitoyens disent et
c'est absolument pas une critique de ce
point de vue c'est une remarque par
rapport au sujet de la question du
patrimoine et de la rénovation et donc
on peut discuter de l'impact du zan sur
la Ferté du prix
ça c'est objectif et c'est un débat que
je comprends on peut discuter de la
difficulté de le mettre en oeuvre en
fonction des trajectoires et des
évolutions mais je pense sincèrement que
sur la question de la rénovation il est
pas crucial et et que si on soulève des
faux débats on aura du mal à se
concentrer sur les vraies réponses
on discutait de ce que notre pays
faisait de bien ou de pas bien on a des
marges d'amélioration sur le patrimoine
mais je suis par exemple frappé de voir
que sur les passoires énergétiques on a
tendance à oublier les locataires
et qu'on plaigne le propriétaire qui va
devoir faire des travaux parce que sinon
il pourra plus louer sa passoire
énergétique je le comprends je suis
parfois choqué qu'on fasse comme s'il y
avait personne dans le logement et que
personne ne s'étonne si les prix de ce
chauffage ne cesse d'augmenter parce
qu'il y a pas eu un minimum de travaux
d'isolation
et après tout il y a un patrimoine qui
peut malgré tout se vendre et d'autres
qui feront peut-être les travaux et ça
s'inscrit aussi dans une logique qui
permet d'aller faire tourner une partie
du capital et de pas figer les choses à
l'intérieur d'un pays
sur le petit patrimoine vous avez
pleinement raison sur le fait qu'il faut
qu'on fasse attention à ne pas focaliser
une politique globale uniquement sur le
grand patrimoine et que le petit il
participe au charme de notre territoire
je pense que c'est plutôt un vrai sujet
sur est-ce qu'on a suffisamment inscrit
ou classé dans un certain nombre de
secteurs et par rapport à des types de
patrimoine qui a une modification
législative qui viendrait prévoir hors
inscription au monument historiques quoi
que ce soit de ce type et en ayant là
aussi un peu d'intelligence sur la
manière dont on applique des éléments
parce que dit autrement
tout le débat qu'on a sur la rénovation
énergétique il doit aussi reposer sur la
fréquence d'utilisation je vais
volontairement prendre un exemple que je
veux pas caricatural mais qui est celui
des églises
si j'ai une église qui est une passoire
thermique ou énergétique
il faut que je me souvienne qu'elle ne
fait pas l'objet d'un usage 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7 avec des gens qui
dorment avec une activité qui se déroule
de manière complète et donc
l'investissement que je vais avoir si je
le rapporte à ce que je vais économiser
il est sans doute écologiquement pas
souhaitable par rapport au matériaux qui
va falloir et au niveau d'investissement
concentre nous sur les logements
occupés et occupés par des gens modestes
qui peuvent pas faire autrement ça c'est
la priorité absolue qu'on doit avoir de
manière collective et sans insulter
l'avenir par rapport à un certain nombre
de choses
en fait je suis je voulais vous dire que
j'étais vraiment complètement d'accord
avec vous par rapport aux ânes je pense
que le Zen peut être une opportunité
magnifique pour le patrimoine si on le
si on le réinvestit comme il le faut
mais l'exemple que enfin j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure j'ai vu chez moi en
Alsace une maison qui a été démolie au
nom du jeune donc je pense qu'en fait il
faut il faut rester vigilant
merci alors il y avait daphnécmadou et
on terminera avec Jean-Jacques Michaud
je vais revenir sur la question
de la prise en compte et de
l'accélération de la réversibilité
immobilière
urbaine et de la surélévation qui sont
des éléments en fait corollaires et liés
aux ânes et liées aussi
à l'autre objectif de rénovation des
bâtiments puisque on les professionnels
tout à l'heure nous en ont parlé c'est à
dire qu'à un moment donné une question
financière donc que ça soit en
réorganisant la parcelle parce qu'on
passe de bureau en logement
pour permettre de se payer cette
transformation et qui va inclure aussi
une transformation forcément énergétique
des bâtiments ou uniquement du logement
logement en surélevant donc il y a
toutes ces questions de la
transformation et à l'heure actuelle en
fait cette question de réversibilité
elle est dans nos textes actuels et dans
notre
code de l'urbanisme mais autre code trop
prise en compte trop peu prise en compte
notamment pour permettre en fait cette
accélération du côté des PLU du côté des
permis de construire avec des usages
évolutifs ce qu'on est capable de faire
par exemple sur les bâtiments des géo Jo
2024 par rapport à l'héritage on doit
pouvoir être capable de le faire d'une
manière beaucoup plus large mais pour ça
il faut
voilà faire vraiment un pas pour
transformer et permettre cet
accélération sans enlever toutes les
normes mais en permettant de l'accélérer
après la question c'est la question
aussi réglementaire qui freine
énormément d'inflation des règles la
question assurantielle
ou de certification technique
on prend l'exemple par exemple de
matériaux biosourcés donc on a évoqué
des matériaux sourcils en fait en termes
de réglementation on est extrêmement
freiné pour pouvoir les utiliser d'une
manière beaucoup plus
et elle permettent eux ils permettent de
répondre à deux objectifs
de la construction et puis un confort
aussi énergétique un deuxième exemple
c'est une entreprise l'entreprise Carnot
qui développe qui chauffe par la donnée
en fait numérique dans le bâtiment et
qui a eu examiné du temps pour obtenir
toutes les certifications qui lui
permettent voilà de Manon d'essayer de
développer ce système qui est plus
adapté à tout ce qui est entrepôt
entreprise et logement collectif et pas
l'individuel pour le moment et le
dernier élément c'est l'obgénalisation
des règles en matière de réglementation
incendie notamment pour permettre cette
réversibilité
dans les bâtiments et y compris sur les
sur les matériaux après le dernier
corollaire et qui auquel j'avais pas
forcément prévu de parler mais que vous
avez évoqué par rapport au m c'est la
question notamment de des moyens de
notre disposition pour protéger
actuellement et notamment pour les élus
les collectivités les espaces verts les
forêts les arbres
on n'est pas encore certains moments
donnés pour pouvoir conserver en fait
nos plus de carbone et valoriser la
partie verte versus la partie
artificialisée il faut à mon sens
renforcer les moyens qu'on a notre
disposition une fois avec des arbres
sont coupés une fois que ds sont coupés
et on a trop peu de moyens actuels
notamment à disposition des mers et des
collectivités pour être efficaces dans
ce domaine là
merci Madame la série alors je n'ai
aucun désaccord avec ce qui vient d'être
dit je vais effectivement précisé ce qui
est la vigilance du ministère de la
transition écologique et plus largement
qu'on doit avoir particulier sur le
biosourcer on a des injonctions
contradictoires entre d'une part le fait
que on sait que dans les angles morts
aujourd'hui de la planification
écologique pardon dans les dans les
difficultés de la planification
écologique il y a le rendement en termes
de stockage de la forêt
le dépérissement de la forêt qui
s'accélère sous l'ampleur du dérèglement
climatique conduit à ce que nous ne
soyons pas au rendez-vous du stockage
les -55%, c'est moins 50 des missions
plus 5 de stockage or nous sommes en
baisse sur le stockage et pourtant ça
n'est pas parce que la forêt recule la
forêt progresse mais elle progresse
d'une manière qui n'est pas organisée et
dès lors qu'elle n'est pas organisée
elle ne produit pas ce stockage
pour qu'elle soit organisée ou qu'il y
ait des débouchés si ce déboucher c'est
le fait d'aller brûler on revient à la
case départ en termes d'émission il faut
donc un stockage qui se fasse dans
l'immeuble ou dans les structures et
aujourd'hui quand je dis aujourd'hui
c'est en ce moment un des sujets c'est
la réglementation incendie des immeubles
à l'intérieur desquels il y a une part
de bois prépondérante et c'est
cette semaine la semaine prochaine que
les discussions sur le sujet ont lieu
pour que on évite de se placer dans une
logique qui est exactement la même que
celle qui conduisait à ce qui est encore
trois mois on ne dise que il faut de
l'eau potable au fond des toilettes et
pas des eaux grises au nom d'une sorte
de principe de précaution qui fait que
on ne bouge rien pensé qu'on affrontera
ce qui arrive sans rien changer c'est
une folie et là encore il faut qu'on
trouve le bon équilibre sur la
réversibilité
la loi climat est résilience à poser un
principe elle s'efforce de le favoriser
d'insister sur la potentialité on n'a
pas encore le réflexe
pourtant c'est un réflexe qui va qui
devrait profondément changer une partie
de ce que nous faisons un des meilleurs
exemples c'est pour les parkings
on s'aperçoit au fur et à mesure des
études que par exemple parking
souterrain qui était pendant longtemps
la norme à quelques inconvénients
y compris dans le l'artificialisation du
sous-sol les conséquences que ça peut
avoir avec parfois les potentiels de
géothermie qu'on pourrait aller chercher
ou des choses de ce type
l'inverse le rez-de-chaussée qui sert de
parking et qui ensuite peut être
transformé parce qu'on est déjà du coup
à un niveau si un jour il y avait moins
de voitures c'est un modèle dont on
mesure qu'il a une certaine
utilité pour l'avoir testé ces derniers
projets que j'ai lancé dans ma ville
la mauvaise foi qui consiste du coup à
faire porter le coût de la réversibilité
sur un équipement destiné aux voitures
peut être de nature à freiner parce que
quand vous on vous dit regardez ça va
coûter une fortune au contribuable parce
qu'évidemment vous dépensez un peu plus
pour que la hauteur sur plafond soit
compatible avec le fait demain de
transformer ça et vous choisissez une
forme avec une sorte de patio centrale
qui permet de s'assurer qu'il y aura une
forme de lumière qui sera disponible
partout
il faut ensuite le faire rentrer dans
les têtes et être capable d'expliquer
que la réversibilité elle a un coût mais
qu'elle est une forme d'assurance
contre une mal adaptation ou contre des
décisions plus tard qui seraient à
conduire je pense que ça a du sens de de
pousser ça l'exemple que vous donnez
pour Carnot je vais pas le reprendre je
crois que je les vois bientôt
dans ce contexte et de manière plus
large le fait de s'appuyer sur des
entreprises
qui ont des qui font de la donnée qui
sont capables d'aller objectiver les
situations je pense que c'est aussi un
des sujets en termes de rénovation des
logements qui est extrêmement important
enfin vous avez cité les deux
difficultés plutôt les deux leviers 3
millions de mètres carrés de bureau
disponible
avec deux difficultés le fait que ça s'y
prête pas forcément
fait qu'il y a certains maires qui ne
voient pas nécessairement d'un bon œil
des mètres carrés qui ne font que
générer de l'impôt et qui vont générer
de la demande de service parce qu'un
habitant
par rapport à une cotisation foncière
des entreprises c'est pas exactement la
même équation et que les bâtiments sont
pas forcément adaptés qu'on peut avoir
en plus une difficulté fiscale pour
l'entreprise qui possède ses bureaux au
moment où elle assure la transition
compte tenu de la valorisation
et l'assurer l'élévation ou là il y a un
vrai enjeu de raconter la ville sur la
ville
mais on n'est plus tout à fait dans la
rénovation au sens large
on se rapproche au contraire de la
formule urbaine et de d'autres questions
de ce type
si ce n'est monsieur le ministre dans la
surélévation on est quand même dans la
rénovation ne serait-ce que pour la
rénovation énergétique des copropriétés
puisque si il y a un projet de
surélévation ça peut permettre
effectivement d'avoir des fonds qui vont
entraîner la copropriété dans la
rénovation énergétique de leur logement
c'était dans cet objectif là et dans
cette perspective qu'on a parlé
précédemment avec les professionnels de
l'immobilier mais on le voit aussi dans
un certain nombre de territoires que ça
peut être quand même une possibilité
pour embarquer des copropriétés dans des
opérations de rénovation énergétique de
logements importants leur copropriété
non seulement je n'ai aucun tabou sur le
sujet mais je pensais m'en tirer à bon
compte en arrêtant là dans ma réponse je
vais je vais la prolonger
mais je suis intimement convaincu que ça
peut être la bonne solution à un certain
endroit la difficulté c'est plutôt les
vis-à-vis et c'est le contexte urbain
dans lequel on se trouve qui peut
éventuellement être limite et ensuite la
nature technique du bâtiment en revanche
ça permet de diviser la charge par un
nombre de mètres carrés plus grand ça
c'est toujours intéressant et d'avoir
effectivement une réserve d'urbanisation
ce que je veux dire à ce sujet
c'est que de toute façon nous ne
pourrons pas faire l'économie une
réflexion sur le vote en copropriété des
travaux de rénovation
dans le cadre de la loi d'orientation
des mobilités
quand il s'agit d'aller poser des bornes
de recharge
le principe de la majorité s'apprécie de
manière différente
on ne requiert pas
on ne calcule pas de la même manière
mais vous le savez très bien et moi je
m'interroge sur le fait de savoir dans
quelle mesure il faudrait pas
effectivement assouplir les possibilités
de vote pour aller vers de la rénovation
énergétique ça pose une difficulté
potentielle c'est les niveaux d'avance
qui sont souhaitables par rapport à
l'hétérogénéité des situations de ceux
qui sont propriétaires
et donc je pense que la seule il y a
deux éléments il y a un élément
juridique qui consiste à simplifier le
mode pour avoir une majorité plus simple
que celle qui parfois est très très
difficile à obtenir mais le corollaire
c'est d'avoir une sorte d'avance qui
puisse être versée à la copropriété pour
éviter que des propriétaires qui
seraient davantage en difficulté se
retrouvent à devoir sortir des sommes
qui ne l'ont pas
ça peut être bien une sorte de pré
collectif exactement
ce que je pense et je vais plus loin
parce que la difficulté c'est que le
refus de la copropriété de faire
certains travaux peut empêcher le
changement de classe de certains biens
l'appartement au nord au rez-de-chaussée
le propriétaire pourra faire tout ce
qu'il veut à un moment et donc il va se
retrouver avec une déperdition
potentielle de son bien le jour où il le
vendra parce que son étiquette
énergétique conduira à ce que
l'acquéreur profite de cette mauvaise
étiquette pour faire baisser le prix
alors que c'est pas sa volonté qui sera
en cause c'est que le mode de chauffage
par exemple de l'immeuble l'empêchera
d'aller gagner la classe qui sera
nécessaire donc quand une majorité
s'oppose je suis profondément démocrate
ici une majorité qui est favorable qui
est large et que les systèmes
spécifiques de votre dans les copro
empêche d'y aller là il faut qu'on
trouve quelque chose pour bouger ça
merci alors Jean-Jacques Michaud
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je reviendrai pas sur le DPE je
vous fais confiance quand vous dites que
ça va devenir un thermomètre fiable et
objectif dans les semaines à venir mais
aujourd'hui c'est quand même un élément
qui n'engendre pas la confiance chez les
personnes la deuxième question est vous
venez d'en parler c'est autant les
propriétaires bailleurs ont bien compris
quand ils sont propriétaires de passoire
énergétique quels étaient les enjeux
pour eux mais c'est pas le cas pour les
propriétaires
occupants qui
bien souvent ne voit pas le retour sur
investissement dans un délai raisonnable
pour leur investissement donc comment
peut-on les engager et en particulier
mais c'est la question que vous avez
traité il y a deux minutes en
particulier dans les copropriété quand
il y a et des propriétaires bailleurs et
des propriétaires occupants et comment
faire pour qu'ils ne viennent pas aux
mains dans les prochaines années
en entendant votre question je souris
parce que Agnès panière une assi a juste
eu le temps de me dire qu'elle avait
botté en couche sur la question des
copropriétés et je me dis que pour faire
la transition avec Olivier Klein ce
serait idéal que je m'arrête là pour ne
pas vous répondre davantage faire en
sorte de prendre les jumeaux donc
sincèrement j'ai commencé en répondant
à la sénatrice précédente esquissée le
fait qu'on a un sujet avec la
Chancellerie sur les droits de vote et
un deuxième sur la solvabilité mais je
vous assure que le ministre délégué à la
ville au logement sera heureux sur le
sujet de vous parler de ça de vous
parler plus largement des copropriétés
dégradées de la situation dans certains
égards il faudrait peut-être un an rue
de la rénovation des copropriétés
ça fait un excellent teasing pour lui
laisser le la parole de
on est bon
une précision vous avez justement faire
le lien avec le DPE vous avez parlé tout
à l'heure de dire qu'il était encore qui
aurait des modifications et qu'on aurait
dans les semaines à venir en tout cas
c'est quoi le calendrier enfin je veux
dire va être vraiment y avoir
des modifications dans les dans les
critères enfin c'est quoi
les éléments que j'ai c'est je vais
reprendre
certains
suite à votre interpellation de dire les
choses de la manière la plus claire qui
soit
on vous précisant et que
la feuille de route
mobiliser etc pour l'été 2023
avec
au-delà de tout ça non seulement la
partie travailler par le ministère de la
Ville et du logement sur la mobilisation
des acteurs et la feuille de route sur
l'amélioration de la qualité de la
réalisation réalisée par le ministère de
la Ville de logement mais également
renforcement de la formation initiale et
continue diagnostiqueur examen contrôle
par les organismes de
certification avec un projet d'arrêté
concerté avec les fédérations et les
organismes qui devraient être soumis au
consultation obligatoire en une
publication à l'été 2023
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre on vous souhaite une bonne
soirée mais je crois que vous n'avez pas
terminé
bon courage
merci à tous merci